G
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
HEATING OIL AND THEY ARE COLD
ALREADY.
THE HEAD OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
DURBIN DROPPED THIS GEM ON
TWITTER:
THIS ASSERTION IS CONTRARY TO
HIS OATH OF OFFICE.
HE HAS TON IT'S WRONG.
THE QUESTION IS WHY THE HEAD OF
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
REDEFINING WHAT FREE SPEECH
MEANS?
WHAT IS THE END GOAL?
HERE GLENN GREENWALD.
SPEECH YOU EVEN FIND VILE IS
ALSO PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE?
>> IF FREE SPEECH IS ONLY FOR
PEOPLE WITH WHOM YOU AGREE, YOU
WOULD NOT NEED FREE SPEECH.
NORM SAID FROM THE LEFT THAT
EVEN HERMAN GORING BELIEVED THAT
FREE SPEECH FOR PEOPLE YOU AGREE
WITH, EVERY DICTATOR BELIEVES
THAT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS THAT
DEMOCRATS SINCE 2016 CONCLUDED
THAT THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN WIN
ELECTIONS IS TO CONTROL THE FLOW
OF INFORMATION OVER THE
INTERNET.
THEY ARE REDEFINING WHAT FREE
SPEECH IS TO MEAN INFORMATION
THAT IS FALSE AS THE GOVERNMENT
DEFINES IT CAN BE CONSTRAINED
AND THOSE WHO EXPRESS IT CAN BE
PUNISHED.
>> Laura: GLENN, A FORMER FBI
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR IS
PIGGYBACKING OFF DURBIN'S
COMMENTS.
>> IT'S NOT FREE SPEECH WITHOUT
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE ARE DUPED INTO THINKING, YOU
DO HAVE THE RIGHT TO SAY
WHATEVER YOU WANT EVEN IF PEOPLE
ARE GETTING KILLED.
WE HAVE BECOME NUMB TO THE
VIOLENT RADICALS AND BECOMING
DUPED INTO THINKING, THAT'S FREE
SPEECH.
>> Laura: WHAT A DOPE.
FREE SPEECH IS NOT SOMETHING YOU
CAN BE DUPED INTO.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS.
THIS IS SHOCKING EVEN FOR HIM.
>> I KEEP TRYING TO SAY THAT
THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE WHERE
PEOPLE DISAGREE WITH DEMOCRATS
ABOUT FREE SPEECH.
THEY REGARD CENSORSHIP AS
CENTRAL.
THAT MEANS YOU COULD ROUNDUP THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTERS WHO
IN 2022 SAID THERE WERE WEAPONS
OF MASS DESTRUCTION IN IRAQ OR
THOSE WHO SAID THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP WAS DISINFORMATION.
THE STATE CAN'T IMPRISON THEM
BECAUSE THAT'S PROTECTED BY THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CONDITION
AMERICANS TO BELIEVE THERE IS
A GREATER ROLE FOR THE STATE
DECIDING WHAT IS TRUE AND FALSE.
WHAT CAN AND CAN'T BE HEARD.
>> Laura: THE ELITES WOULD LIKE
A GLOBAL AGREEMENT ABOUT WHAT
FREE SPEECH SHOULD MEAN.
FRANCE DEMANDED THAT THE VIDEO
PLATFORM RUMBLE REMOVE ALL
CONTENT FROM THE RUSSIAN
NETWORK.
RUMBLE REFUSED AND PULLED THEIR
PLATFORM FROM THE COUNTRY AND
ARE LOOKING INTO A LEGAL
CHALLENGE.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS IT WE HAVE
NATIONS TRYING TO BULLY PRIVATE
COMPANIES INTO CENSORSHIP?
THIS IS BIZARRE.
>> WHAT IS ALARMING IS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR IN UKRAINE
THE ENTIRE EU MADE IT ILLEGAL
FOR PLATFORMS TO BROADCAST
RUSSIA STATE MEDIA.
WATCHING THEM SHOULD BE YOUR
CHOICE.
THE EU SAID IT'S NOT YOUR
IF YOU ARE A CITIZEN YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO ACCESS THOSE OUTLETS
TO HEAR WHAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
SAYING.
THEY ARE REACHING OVER TO
AMERICAN COMPANIES LIKE RUMBLE
SAYING WE DEMAND YOU TAKE OFF
THE NEWS SITES WE DISLIKE.
IF YOU ARE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
YOU WILL BE TOLD NOT BY
A GOVERNMENT YOU ELECTED BUT
GOVERNMENTS IN EUROPE, CHINA OR
IRAN, THAT YOU WILL BE DICTATED
TO YOU WHAT YOU CAN AND CAN'T
HEAR.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT RUMBLE TOLD
THE FRENCH GOVERNMENT THEY WOULD
NOT COMPLY.
>> Laura: I AM THRILLED THEY ARE
DOING THAT.
GLENN, THE